welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where they all float with it
chapter 2 closing the book on the Battle
of the losers Club versus penny wise I
thought I'd revisit one of my older
videos and bring it fully up today with
the new movie I just want to give a huge
thank you to everyone who watched the
breakdown last time and thanks for
getting it to six million views you guys
are the best and a massively appreciate
all of the support on the channel once
again I've been through both films with
a fine-tooth comb to let you know all of
the times that penny wise popped up in
the background of scenes and this is now
the definitive list for every appearance
of the character it's crazy the amount
of times that he pops up and hopefully
this list will enrich in your love for
the two films by showing you just how
much of a hold that the killer Klown has
on the town of Derry there's gonna be
huge spoilers here so if you haven't had
a chance to watch both films yet then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way let's get into my
breakdown of every time that penny wise
was hidden away in the background of a
scene okay so while this start in the
beginning of it chapter one within the
first five minutes before Georgie even
comes face to face with the character in
the sewers as Georgie makes his way down
to the basement he passes several
impressions of Pennywise and even almost
bumps into the character directly when
making his way down the stairs to the
bottom part of the house throughout his
home there were several images of
Pennywise ingrained into the wallpaper
as Georgie makes his way to get the wax
and in a blink in you'll miss a moment
that roughly takes place over two frames
you may also know as penny wise his
small shiny eyes watching the young boy
at the top of the stairs as he descends
the flight of steps this is the first of
many examples that shows that it's
always one step behind its prey
constantly stalking them and waiting for
the perfect moment to attack whilst it
also appears later in the scene hiding
under the stairs who knows how long it
followed Georgie fall before making its
attack however it does semaine that once
Pennywise has its eyes on you it's
difficult to get away up next is the
library scene with Ben in which there
are several minor appearances by penny
wise before he makes his final play and
tries to attack the car
in the basement of the building I guess
the rule is if there's a killer Klown
after you just don't go downstairs
anywhere anyway the first one comes in
the form of the creepy librarian that
slowly watches Ben as he reads about the
history of Derry throughout the seen the
mysterious librarian creepily stares at
him smiling as he digs deeper into what
exactly may be going on in the town it's
a really haunting scene and is something
that I didn't even pick up on my first
couple of watches though the more you
focus on the background of the scene the
more you realize that Pennywise is
slowly making his play I know it was
comments last time and people saying it
was just a woman doing a job but she's
also standing in the exact same position
that the balloon appears in in the next
shot that leads Ben to go down into the
basement which cements for me that the
character is indeed taking on her form
another blink in your missive moment
also happens in the scene when Ben is
flicking through the book in a small
frame that flies by so fast you have to
screenshot in order to see it you will
see it in the children's Easter egg hunt
that infamously ended in disaster in the
top corner of the photo when paused
you'll notice a blurry vision of
Pennywise that shows it was the cause
behind the massacre and has been in the
town at several key points as we know
from eight-penny wises often at the
center of many famous disasters in Derry
and this confirms that it was indeed
behind the many deaths in the Easter egg
hunt soon after this scene Ben is caught
by Henry Bowers and we see a balloon pop
up in the back window of a car during
the attack as he calls out for help it
goes completely unnoticed and this shows
that Pennywise has a hold over the
adults in Derry and is physically
controlling them so that they will
appear nonchalant to any trouble at the
children in the area get into this is
why Beverly's father can't see the blood
in the bathroom and why in one of the
films many deleted scenes Bill's father
is unable to see that the basement is
flooded after the encounter with Georgie
and Pennywise down there whilst the one
in the car is rather obvious and adds a
nice amount of subtext to the city and
definitely lets you know that Pennywise
has the ability to reach into pretty
much every aspect of Derry the next one
comes during the scene in which the
losers Club try and help Ben with his
cuts the characters are all leaning up
against the wall with graffiti behind
them which seems innocuous enough until
during the scene Pennywise his face
appears in the marking
watching them the face definitely isn't
there earlier in the scene so it's safe
to say that this has been done with
something else other than a spray can
it's an awesome little addition that
once again cements just how able
Pennywise is with hunting is prey it can
follow them wherever it wants to and
this makes it infinitely more terrifying
up next is another rather obvious one
but I thought I'd include it in case you
missed it during the scene in which the
losers Club all admit that they're
afraid of something we can see a clown
on the stage in the background staring
at the group and when Richie says that
he hates clowns the figure reaches out
menacingly to him with the balloon and
from this point just stares at him now
we can in fact confirm that that is
Pennywise the clown is actually played
by Bill skarsgård who also plays penny
wise so it's clear that he's using the
forum to spy on the children and this
scene is given more weight in his
chapter two when Richie is haunted by
the creature at the same location penny
wise also makes an appearance in the TV
show that seems to be plastered across
every television screen and dairy whilst
penny wise definitely does appear in it
at the end
taunting Henry to kill his own father if
you go back and watch the movie you will
notice that this show also appears in
the rest of the film throughout the
entire town firstly Eddie's mother is
sat watching it when the children go out
and later Beverly sneaks past her father
who too is watching it so it might just
be a great thing to watch like the heavy
spoilers show right well you can
actually hear the woman in the show say
it's okay to go and play in the sewers
it's safe and fun this is of course
telling children to enter penny Wiser's
domain and to potentially become its
next meal so yeah it's definitely
probably the creepiest thing that anyone
could be watching sitting next to the
presenter are the missing children from
Derry who all have severe wounds in
their body that probably indicate the
brutal way that Pennywise killed them
this entire TV show is another method
that penny wise uses to control the town
and what makes it clear that penny wise
is behind it all is cemented by the fact
that it's plain when Beverly sneaks past
her father then when we cut back to the
TV moments later it's just playing
static next up on the way to the house
on your belt street before the losers
Club enter we can see a bottle with Bob
Gray written on it which is a callback
to penny wise who famously used the
moniker Bob gray is a reference to the
serial killer Albert
fish who - used the pseudonym when
carrying out his killings the final one
in the film comes in the house and near
bolt street in which Ricci becomes
trapped in a room full of dolls not only
is there one that resembles the original
Pennywise portrayed by Tim Curry in the
1990s miniseries there's also one that
looks like the updated version on the
right hand side both sides of the room
show the history of Pennywise and it
showcases that the character was
watching Ricci far before he jumped out
of the coffin to attack him and that's
all of the ones from it chapter one and
before we move on I just wanted to point
out one that you might have missed in
spider-man far from home this one's way
too short to do a full video on but
early on in the film at the 18 minute
mark
Jake Gyllenhaal aka Mysterio can be seen
stalking Peter Parker way before he's
formally introduced to the character not
only does Mysterio pull a penny wise
here but he also puts illusions into
people's heads so I thought I'd include
this in this list anyway back to it
chapter two the first one that we see in
the film is during the introductory
logos in which we can see the dead
lights flowing around the Warner
Brothers and New Line logo this is a
nice way to kickstart the movie and that
lets us know that these will be major
parts of the film when we're introduced
to Henry Bowers we can see in his room
images of penny wise on the wall most
notably a red balloon which shows that
he never really caught out of his head
the next major one we see appears during
Mike's vision of how to carry out the
ritual of chert when viewing how it came
to dairy we can see a form of Pennywise
standing behind Mike mimicking his
movements and also in the scene we see
the original form that it used to attack
the Native Americans in the area which
was a giant bird and huge beasts one of
the forms first but second looks like
the original spider form that is seen at
the end of the 1990s miniseries and in
Mike's room is actually a poster with
Pennywise on which is promoting the
dairy Canal days there's no reason that
Mike would want to have an image up of
the thing that scared him the most
throughout his entire life so I have a
sneaking suspicion that penny wise put
it there himself the next one is pretty
obvious and was shown in the teaser
trailer for the film this is Bob gray
who in the scene we discover was a
victim and alter-ego that penny wise
adopted at the star of the prior century
in Terry this callback to the ball from
the previous film is nice and there's
also some hints that penny wises in the
room just before Beverly enters it you
including the door which says Marsh
before changes to Kirsch and when
Beverly Knoxville scars God's voice can
be heard answering the door and asking
who's there
this shows that Pennywise probably made
us play at the last second and jump
there creating the illusion just before
Beverly knocked when Ben revisits the
school we also get a hint that Pennywise
is in fact using Beverly's form as its
shadow appears in front of the projector
before there's seemingly a fake out and
we see that it's just Bev well in
hindsight we know that this was indeed
the character popping up to a know Ben
before quickly changing its form to try
and get him to let his guard down I
guess you should just never go to summer
school
or whenever this was that Ben attended a
it was also fighting the creature making
friends and building an underground
bunker yeah some of these raccoons don't
work anyway we also see a cameo by Annie
machete director of the film when Eddy
visits the pharmacy I have no idea why
that's in this list I just thought I'd
put it in there as a nice little easter
egg
anyway when bill chases the boy that now
lives in his old house at the funfair in
order to save him from the snatch of the
killer clown we can see several elements
of the funhouse that featured the 1990s
miniseries penny wise played by Tim
Curry they're not your typical punching
bags as they all must knock bill off his
feet when banging into him showing that
penny wise always packs a punch and
finally at the end of the movie when
Beverly is in the bathroom against the
wall we can see a graffiti version of
penny wise pressed into the stall this
isn't in the stall in the first film
when Beverly sits there and is tormented
by Greta the bully so it looks like this
was later added by the creature in order
to leave an impression this crudely
drawn kid's version of the character
lets you know that penny wise will
always be a part of dairy one way or
another and it's a nice little squiggle
that holds a lot more weight to it and a
simple drawing and that's every time
that I noticed penny wise popping up in
the background of a scene in both films
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on these did you notice them and have
you spotted any more comment below and
let me know and if you enjoy this video
then please give it a thumbs up and if
you want something else to watch after
this then make sure you check out my
breakdown of the upcoming it's super
curt that's been confirmed by director
Andy mache I go over all of the scenes
I'll be added into it as well as some of
the new ones so it's definitely worth
checking out a few
no more if you want to come talk to me
about movies TV shows games and comic
books and you can follow me on twitter
at definition YT it's the best way to
get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content so hopefully I see over there up
to this also just one let you know that
we're giving away a free copy of
spider-man far from home on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning and still like this
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts and
the penny wise appearances in the
comment section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th and the blue arrow be
shipped out from then whoever gets the
prize so best of luck to everyone he
takes part this is the channel for
people who were mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
you